Olá pessoal aqui o Dr Alan Machado Dutra
médico há mais de 25 anos se você está
buscando uma solução eficaz e natural
Para apoiar sua saúde cerebral
especialmente turbinar o seu foco e
concentração e memória hoje eu vou
compartilhar com você cinco ervas
Poderosas que podem aprimorar e te
beneficiar incrivelmente essas ervas têm
um efeito de neuroproteção e de melhora
da saúde mental da função cognitiva como
um todo são conhecidas como com ervas
nootrópico excelentes também para quem
está passando por período de estresse ou
ansiedade seja por um estresse pontual
por causa de uma prova na faculdade ou
um projeto no seu trabalho ou até mesmo
dificuldades nas rotinas do dia a dia
sabe quando você acorda e precisa fazer
uma certa tarefa mas sente aquela falta
de concentração aquela falta de energia
mental essas Hervas podem ajudar você
nesses sintomas porque elas atuam de uma
maneira bem interessante nos
neurotransmissores que são os
responsáveis pela transmissão dos sinais
elétricos do nosso cérebro elas afetam
de forma positiva concentração em
memória ajudando na produção de
neurotransmissores como acetilcolina a
dopamina noradrenalina e o gaba que são
todos fundamentais em todo o processo
mas o que são exatamente as ervas
nootrópico o termo nootrópico é usado
para se referir a uma substância que
aumenta a capacidade intelectual sem
causar efeitos colaterais graves ou
significativos como acontece por exemplo
com muitos medicamentos da Indústria
Farmacêutica Então a primeira Eva é a
panax jinzen que também é conhecida como
jinzen asiático ou jinzen vermelho
coreano é uma erva é uma raiz
adaptógenas e noot trópica que tem
propriedades antiinflamatórias e
antioxidantes muito potentes uma
excelente opção porque estudos sugerem
que ela pode até prolongar a vida sendo
considerada uma erva antienvelhecimento
Interessante não é no contexto da nossa
conversa sobre a saúde cognitiva ela
atua muito bem na melhoria da memória da
concentração e da clareza mental os
componentes ativos do jinzen chamado
jinzen oídos são bem conhecidos por
modular a atividade do nossos
neurotransmissores Além disso O Gin zeng
aumenta os níveis do fator neurotrófico
derivado do cérebro bdnf que desempenha
um papel importante na saúde do nosso
sistema nervoso central ao ajudar o bdnf
esse neurotrófico o Jin zeng protege o
cérebro contra estresse oxidativo e
melhora o desempenho mental Eu considero
o Gin zeng uma ótima escolha por exemplo
para estudantes que estão em períodos de
provas importantes e não consegue se
concentrar ou para profissionais que
estão em momentos decisivos e bus busca
aumentar a clareza mental e o foco é
realmente uma erva muito interessante
para esses casos a segunda erva é a
bacopa moniere a bacopa possui
propriedades incríveis para melhorar a
memória sendo uma das melhores ervas
para Esse aspecto vários estudos mostram
que ela pode ajudar bastante a função
cognitiva principalmente porque ela
melhora a comunicação entre as células
cerebrais entre os neurônios o
ingrediente ativo da bacopa os Bacos tem
um papel bem documentado na
neuroproteção protegendo nossos
neurônios e o cérebro como um todo a
bacopa Manieri vai melhorar a memória e
o aprendizado de forma significativa E
além disso tem uma atuação bem
interessante na redução da ansiedade
pessoas ansiosas que também estão
enfrentando dificuldades cognitivas vão
se beneficiar muito da bacopa monié
agora vou falar um pouco sobre rodiola
Rosia eu gosto muito dessa erva porque
além de melhorar a memória a
concentração ela pode ajudar a reduzir a
fadiga e melhorar nossa capacidade de
enfrentar períodos de estresse Então ela
é uma erva
adaptógenas estudos mostram que ela
também possui propriedades
antidepressivas sendo uma ótima opção
para pessoas que estão passando por uma
depressão leve moderada além de ajudar
no combate ao estresse e depressão A
rodiola também combate a fadiga mental
aumenta o foco melhora a função
cognitiva E olha que interessante a
rodiola ros
Ainda ajuda a aumentar a atenção aos
detalhes mínimos ajuda na velocidade de
processamento cognitivo e na capacidade
de realizar multitarefas com mais
eficiência Então ela é uma erva muito
interessante mesmo que você não esteja
passando por depressão ou períodos de
estresse a rodiola Rosia ainda vai
ajudar ela vai atuar na melhora da parte
cognitiva tornando o seu funcionamento
mental mais eficiente a quarta erva que
eu quero compartilhar com vocês é a
Chanda essa é uma erva também adaptó
muito conhecida e conceituada na
medicina natural vem da Medicina
Ayurveda indiana tem um histórico de
reforçar a memória e melhorar a
concentração Além disso ela é famosa por
suas propriedades de redução do estresse
pois ajuda a equilibrar os níveis de
cortisol e o cortisol como muitos de
vocês sabem é o hormônio do estresse é
um deles mais importante mas tem funções
muito importantes também ligados a
outras ações e precisa estar em
equilíbrio e Ach gand ajuda nesse
equilíbrio então combater o stresse com
essa erva é interessante pois cria um
ambiente ideal para que nossa memória e
função cognitiva esteja em plena
capacidade então a ch Ganda vai apoiar
vai dar suporte a Regeneração das
células cerebrais estabilizar as
substâncias químicas responsáveis pelo
aprendizado e pela memória ela é uma uma
excelente escolha para quem busca um
suporte natural e eficaz para melhorar a
saúde especialmente a saúde mental e a
capacidade cognitiva pessoal a quinta
era é o Jin cobiloba que eu acredito que
muitos de vocês já ouviram falar porque
é bem
famoso Inclusive eu tenho um vídeo sobre
Jin cobiloba no canal eu vou deixar o
link na descrição o ginkobiloba é uma
árvore com propriedades fantásticas e
muito interessantes ela tem potentes
propriedades antioxidantes e consegue
aumentar o fluxo sanguíneo cerebral
melhorando o fornecimento de oxigênio e
protegendo contra danos causados pelo
radicais livres o jinko é Talvez uma das
ervas
neotrópicos no mundo S importância na
melhoria da função cognitiva é bem
notável porque ela atua no declínio
cognitivo aumentando a capacidade de
atenção melhorando o processamento da
memória e também é especialmente
interessante para casos de Alzheimer e
outras demências a atuação do gicu
Biloba no cérebro relacionada à cognição
e ao envelhecimento é realmente
impressionante então para quem busca uma
forma natural de ter mais concentração e
foco de melhorar a memória e proteger o
cérebro contra o envelhecimento o gcub
Biloba é uma escolha muito interessante
é uma escolha excelente bom você deve
estar se perguntando posso utilizar
cinco ervas que foram mencionadas aqui
de forma simultânea tem combinações
entre elas é possível fazer uma Fórmula
conjunta e a resposta é sim Muitas delas
podem ser combinadas e usadas numa mesma
fórmula para obter um efeito mais
potente ainda melhor no entanto isso vai
de caso a caso e deve ser avaliado de
forma individual e por um médico é
importante considerar o que você deseja
alcançar Quais aspectos da sua cognição
e saúde mental você deseja melhorar e
isso deve estar de acordo com a
avaliação dos seus exames histórico
médico para que possa entender qual
combinação é melhor para você mas
pessoal não podemos esquecer do básico
não adianta apenas utilizar essas erva
se você não faz o básico não dá atenção
aos fundamentos da Saúde como beber água
de forma adequada dormir direito
atividade física alimentação dieta a
hidratação é crucial Especialmente
quando você utiliza qualquer tipo de
fórmula fazer exercício regular também é
essencial pois pode melhorar muito a
saúde cognitiva Não esqueça de cuidado
do Sono muitas pessoas querem melhorar o
foco a concentração e a capacidade de
aprendizado mas dormem mal o sono é
muito importante é fundamental pra
função cognitiva muitas vezes mudanças
simples como beber mais água praticar
exercícios dormir bem e melhorar
alimentação já são o suficientes para
melhorar a saúde cognitiva mesmo sem o
uso de ervas Esses são temas recorrentes
no canal e você pode encontrar diversos
vídeos sobre hidratação alimentação
saudável e os melhores alimentos paraa
função cerebral se você decidir utilizar
qualquer uma dessas ervas not trópicas é
sempre interessante iniciar com doses
menores e aumentando aos poucos de forma
gradual dessa forma você pode descobrir
o que está funcionando melhor e qual que
é a dose ideal para você e pode ser
também que você tenha alguma
sensibilidade Nem sempre a maior dose é
é melhor para todo mundo e doses altas
podem causar efeitos colaterais o que é
menos provável com doses
menores outras dicas importantes tomem
cuidado com a procedência das Ervas não
comprem em qualquer lugar se forem
manipular façam isso numa famácia
magistral de manipulação conhecida de
confiança de preferência por indicação
evitem suplementos vendidos baratos em
sites na Internet e-commerce pois muitos
podem não conter o que prometem e
lembre-se de que em caso de mal-estar
dor de cabeça qualquer efeito adverso é
fundamental interromper o uso da erva e
consultar o seu médico sua saúde é
prioridade então sempre busque
orientação profissional ao incorporar
novos suplementos ou ervas em sua rotina
compartilhe os vídeos faç bem a vida de
alguém pode mudar
também
[Música]
can Muito obrigado pela sua atenção um
grande abraço um beijo no seu coração
Você é fera